books only one writer had complete
access to the World Trade Center site
after September 11 2001 William Lang go
Asia
his new book American ground chronicles
the five months he spent with fireman
policeman construction workers and
engineers as they embarked on a massive
recovery effort this program is about an
hour tonight it's a pleasure to
introduce William Longo Esha the
national correspondent for The Atlantic
Monthly and the author of the book
American ground which was serialized in
three parts in the Atlantic Monthly mr.
Longo Asia is the author of several
other books including cutting foreground
about the American Mexican American
border a wonderful meditation on flight
and currently the most recent book
American ground which was a thoroughly
researched and incredibly grueling
account of what it took to take away
what he I think estimated to be 90% of
the remains of the Trade Center all of
which was still at the site after the
collapse he can tell you this better
than I can and the way the evening will
go is that we will have mr. language
read and talk there will be a brief Q&A
from the audience and that will be
followed by a press briefing briefing at
the end of it mr. William mango Isha
well thank you all for being here these
circumstances are obviously unusual for
book reading and and I'd like to just
talk about that a little bit to lay a
little of the scope first before
proceeding with some of the more
traditional aspects of a book reading
this book which is was a three-part
Atlantic series was the result of
extensive reporting at the site and a
serious commitment by me the Atlantic
and fair Straus to do what I think of
and thought of at the time as writing
and observing history in the present
tense it was very obvious to me
I'm an American that this was emotional
terrain it was emotional for me I mean I
felt the same shock I think that all
Americans felt I did not feel the same
grief that the families felt who lost
people but I felt the fundamental shock
of these of this attack and I recognized
the very serious nature of it and the
very serious nature of the response I
took that seriously in other words it I
it was my goal from the beginning
not to write about the events of 9/11
but to write about how the United States
in this very specific and confined space
reacted to it this was not a book of
generalizations this is a book of
precise observations the observations
were either eyewitness observations or
based on sources that were extremely
reliable and had proved themselves to be
reliable in close collaboration over
months of intense work very early on I
passed the boundary between observer and
participant on an emotional level and on
other levels in fact I think of the
American ground series as being a form
of partition
Haitian and probably a useful one so
having said that it is not surprising I
mean it's it is not as if I didn't know
what the emotional terrain there was I
was very aware of it in fact I wrote
about it and and I in fact have enormous
sympathy not only for the people who
lost family there and I met and talked
to many of them though I never wrote
about them during my time of the site
but also for people like the firemen who
were members of fraternal organizations
that were very heavily hit there is I
have no doubt about the sincerity of the
emotions outside tonight and I also
think this is a book called American
ground that that differing perspectives
are entirely legitimate and I accept
that
wholeheartedly I am an American in fact
this book is about to a large extent
that the problem is that it's not about
a sort of lockstep patriotism but
something more fundamentally healthy
that was going on there and it is a
celebration of the United States so
having said that as sort of a groundwork
for I will read a little bit here and
then talk to you a little bit and then
we might have a little Q&A this book
originally started as as the idea of
being a simply an engineering book I
should also say that along with the
focus of this book being the events
following 9/11 it was the focus was not
on the tragedy or the tragic aspects of
it but on the other sort of active
aspects of the response not the
recognition of sorrow which we all had
which was relatively easy for us to
recognize enough said how do you feel I
feel bad but the more complicated thing
that was going on which was very
positive actually in this very sad
ground and
was this this practical American looking
forward moving forward rushing forward
into a solution originally it was going
to be about the engineering only how do
you how do you engineer this tangled
mess with an acknowledgement of the
symbolic importance here and political
importance but of course very rapidly it
became something else
it became the story and something more
interesting and ultimately more more
hopeful about the United States it
became the story of a of a raw cultural
emergence that said a lot about who we
as a country are and what it said was
very hopeful that is what this book is
the site the site roared 24 hours a day
for nine full months and Beyond from
autumn through winter and into spring
the crews labored in 12-hour shifts got
some sleep and came back for more the
enormous scale of the workplace is
difficult to convey under mater Mayor
Rudolph Giuliani's insistence that New
York returned quickly to normal the
restricted zone had shrunk by late
September to 40 downtown blocks bounded
by chambers Broadway rector and the
Hudson River which is still a large area
to be out of commission at the heart of
it under the skeletal walls rising to
150 feet above the street the debris
spread across 17 acres and smoldering
mounds it was dangerous ground of course
workers at the site called it simply the
pile in detail the topography was
complex with strange craters and caves
unstable cliffs and unexpected remnants
of the World Trade Center as it had been
before
the torn sculptural sphere on the ruined
plaza the amputated stores with their
displays of goods no longer for sale a
row of bicycles still securely chained
to a rack a lamppost here or there are
still standing passers-by peering at the
ruins from afar from beyond the
perimeter fences along Broadway or
chambers sometimes expressed amazement
the 210 storey buildings could collapse
into a mass that was relatively so small
but there was no mystery to the demand
because the twin towers had been as much
90% air and 10% structure they had
contained the equivalent of
approximately 11 solid storeys of steel
and concrete and beneath these uneven
mounds which stood five stories high and
spilled into the streets their remnants
filled the foundation hole to bedrock
six levels down indeed from the workers
clothes in view the ruins accounted for
the former buildings all too precisely
it became apparent that the initial
release of powdered concrete into the
air however large it had been had
amounted to an insignificant proportion
of the total weight and that almost
every pound of the original structure
remained to be extracted inspected and
hauled away so the ruins were not small
at all on the scale of people at the
site they were in fact gargantuan not
mounds but mountains that reduce the
expedition's venturing out across them
to an sized columns traversing steel
slopes more than 1.5 million tons of
heavy steel and debris lay densely
compacted there tied together like steel
wool and complicated by the existence of
human remains the weight alone defied
imagination what does a chaos of 1.5
million tons really mean what does it
even look like the scene up-close was so
large that no one quite knew in other
countries clear answers would have been
sought before action was taken learn at
committees would have been formed and
high authorities consulted the ruins
would have been pondered and a tightly
scripted response would have been
imposed barring that soldiers would have
assumed control but for whatever reasons
probably cultural probably profound
little of the sort happened here where
the learning committees were excluded
and the soldiers were relegated to the
unhappy role of guarding the perimeter
and civilians and heavy machines simply
rolled in and took on the unknown the
most effective of these machines were
giant diesel excavators tracked monsters
with hydraulic arms and grappler claws
that could tear tangles or closed around
sections of heavy beams and worried them
clear of the piles embrace they were
voracious in cautious ignorant and
unstoppable
soon there were dozens of them in action
painted orange or yellow working in
tandem to daisy-chain that debris down
the to the trucking operation in the
streets straining under their loads with
smoke and dust rising around them in
flames licking their claws for months
this was how the unbuilding went like a
dance of dinosaurs in a volcanic land of
Steel with men there too moving through
restlessly searching for their kind the
effects were astonishing though the
enormousness of the ruins made the final
goal of a clean hole seemed remote and
difficult to imagine the surface
features of the pile changed so fast
that time itself was compressed and
memories just a week old grew faint
people got caught up in that many of the
core group were camped in hotels or
temporary apartments nearby
the smart ones reminded themselves that
they had recently led ordinary lives and
that they would return to them but weeks
felt like months and months like years
and his winter came it was ordinary life
and not the sight that began to seem
dreamlike and far away that's enough
reading you're all New Yorkers I'm sure
you all know exactly what I'm talking
about at least seen from the outside the
real story here however was not this
debris this terrain but the the ability
as I mentioned in this reading of the
American system to allow the unexpected
to happen this was I saw it very early
and I realized that here here on this
ground in this chaos was a piece of
America which could not be spun ok it
was a piece of America and for which
there would be no no public relations
nope no real political input for a long
time not even engineering and safety
plans none of it meant anything there
and emerging in that chaos and from that
chaos was something very real almost by
definition about what the United States
is at this time or was at this time of
enormous stress for all of us what I saw
emerging as I alluded to in what I
I wrote here was the ability of the
American system having thrown up a
pretty opaque perimeter around this site
an act of brilliance to allow the
unexpected players to play to allow
people who are not anointed either by
action plans or by society at large to
emerge and often in ways that could not
have been predicted that was the common
denominator of the people who rose to
power and took the most effective action
and were allowed to take the most
effective defective action at the Trade
Center site and that common denominator
was that they were unexpected mayor
giuliani who received much credit well
deserved for his lack for his basically
courageous response to the attack in the
days that followed at a time when all of
us felt fear mayor Giuliani did
something that has not really been
acknowledged and then in my opinion for
as someone on the inside was the true
act of brilliance and that was to allow
this to happen
not to impose the OEM plans not to allow
or basically to negotiate and to
persuade people who were already willing
to be persuaded for ideological reasons
this was an American not in New York
story for ideological reasons there were
people in the federal government and the
Office of Emergency Management who were
equally brilliant who were equally
willing to put their their money where
their mouth is
in terms of ideology and theoretical
understanding of how to go about this
this reaction to the crime and tragedy
of September 11th also apparently though
I don't know this firsthand the mayor
the the governor's office was involved
in the innocent but I know it was a
formal decision it was a conscious
decision it was precarious day by day
actually hour by hour in the beginning
and then day by day at a time when there
was no real structure on the inside of
that perimeter when there were probably
15 people who were sort of in charge and
maybe each of them thought had a
slightly more pyramidical view
of the structure that actually was
warranted at a time when there truly was
chaos in terms of the reactions physical
reactions and planning on the ground
within that that perimeter these people
encouraged it allowed it to happen and I
have recently run into some people at
the Pentagon who have read this book
with some interest because they've told
me that it exhibits something they call
swarming behavior and the people in the
military are looking at erect the
perimeter and let and give people let
people do what they can let the natural
leaders emerge apparently also on this
book tour I have been told on this book
tour that apparently on d-day the
Normandy invasion there was very similar
a very similar reaction as the structure
bore the brunt of the German defense and
was Chev of command the structure
command bore that that that attack
basically and was shattered the
unexpected ones rose up and took command
and made decisions that were very
important to the to the success of that
particular invasion I'm not surprised
in other words I don't think that what
we're looking at here at the Trade
Center site only happens at the Trade
Center far from it I mean I think that
this is a fundamentally American thing
and it was heartening to see it in our
modern times now I can give you a few
examples of people who did rise up this
book is really the story of those people
this book is a story of their success
and of success in general not a failure
I'll name two of them one of them I
expected here tonight and I think he has
not as I best I know showed up I
understand
Peter Rinaldi Peter Rinaldi was the man
who who came in who was that he was a
Port Authority engineer he came into the
site in about after the first week as
you all know the Port Authority being
New Yorkers is a highly paternalistic
organization
it's a cocoon for the people who work
there it is in many ways a very
effective organization of course it was
the owner of the Trade Center Peter
Rinaldi who lost his offices and many of
his friends
there had suffered through the shock of
that like the Port Authority itself had
retreated to New Jersey temporarily and
was the was one of the first people one
of the first people sent by the Port
Authority onto the site I remember when
he came in he was an engineer I remember
seeing what I saw what I saw what I
thought of as something close to well
certainly the deep uncertainty in his
eyes this was a man who had had his
cocoon stripped away from him for the
first time in life he was standing in
the wind he was going to have to make
decisions here that were critical and
this is when the the when survivors were
still being sought decisions that were
critical and on which lives depended
about specific technical removal
problems especially on the ground and
Rinaldi I realized I realized that
Rinaldi was not afraid for himself
because I accompanied Rinaldi right away
on some very risky trips underground and
you could see that he was not afraid of
dying and he was not afraid of physical
injury but he was afraid of I think I'm
saying afraid is too strong a word but
he was legitimately concerned with being
exposed to to the wind for the first
time professional time in his life and
with the story of the trade center that
runs all through this book is the story
of Peter and all these emergence I mean
not only did Peter Rinaldi learn things
about himself and discover these
enormous strengths that he had inside of
him that had never come out before that
had not sort of been allowed to the the
independence of thought and the
necessary balance between aggression and
timidity others learned at about and -
that was part of the brilliance these
were not just people discovering things
about themselves this was the new
society the new hidden culture of the
Trade Center site discovering it about
them - and acknowledging it and allowing
them to go forward Rinaldi was one he
rose to enormous power within the site
and became the one engineer who needed
to be consulted on just about everything
and not just below ground but above
ground as well it was his fundamental
judgment rather than his technical
knowledge his ability to stand in the
wind and to operate without committees
and memos that really counted this was
then finally because the United States
is a society
which people can move beyond what they
were before not that we're not Rinaldi
was a mid-level even a high-level
engineer but now he is the man who's
running the the the Port Authority the
trade center site so that's one case
another case a little bit more difficult
maybe is my friend Mike Burton Burton
who became known it was called by the
the press as the Czar of the Trade
Center site was it was driven by first
of all like everybody there a need and
personal need to react effectively to
the terror of the attack a need to
respond as a as a human being let alone
as an American to what had happened he
also I think was I know was personally a
very ambitious man and he grew to
understand that this was an important
moment for him and it was and there was
nothing wrong that I've written frankly
about him as I've written frankly about
everything that I saw or actually
thought in the first person at this site
in the case of Mike Burton he has not
been entirely happy with what I wrote
and I've talked to him about this I have
we have talked in some detail and didn't
some depth about this and I said that my
role unfortunately is to be frank and I
will say things that I believe are
correct even if they are impolite and
even if they are offensive to a man I
count as a friend for instance and I
believe in in some way he's he's
accepting of that at this point that
remains to be seen
so essentially this book is the story of
the intertwining of these characters now
I'll tell you a little bit more about it
and as pertains somewhat to what's going
on outside tonight if you had to pick a
turning point for the people who were
doing
building and let me remind you I was
writing about the unbuild errs here
originally an engineering story it was a
a crisis of emotion somewhat like that
tonight it was a meeting that occurred
at the time when the city government was
beginning to to wrest control of the
site from the fire department and a
meeting of widows was called Giuliani
was there
Mike Burton the Czar was there his
lieutenant Bill Cody was there and the
medical examiner was there there may
have been a few others I'm not aware of
at that site which was extremely at that
meeting which was extremely emotional I
believe it was held in the Sheraton I
may be wrong about that I was not there
as in many cases here I was told this by
very reliable people multiple times the
at that at that meeting things got very
very emotional there was finally no
response possible for a guy like the
medical examiner or for Mike Burton who
simply stood up and took the heat it was
an outpouring of emotion that was beyond
conversation but rather than just
rejecting it which was certainly what
one might expect from a got some
engineers in the construction business
who were interested in pure efficiency
and let's get this job done and by the
way were personally ambitious rather
than just rejecting it there was a
reassessment that occurred at that point
and and the czar Mike Burton and Bill
Cody went to have a beer and they were
very shocked and they recognized to each
other that the emotions that they had
just encountered difficult though they
were to answer were very very real very
legitimate and they needed to take this
into account
they did not stiff arm the emotions
the struggle continued the struggle
continued to the very end between
between efficiency and Memorial ISM you
could say between looking between
looking ahead and looking back that
struggle continued but Burton and Cody
and the rest of them who were in the
unbuilding on the unbuilding side
recognized the validity of the
opposition I recognize the validity of
the opposition it's really a very
similar thing I'll tell you one more
thing and then and then close it there
was at the site a shared understanding
despite the divisions that I have
written about because I write frankly
about things despite the fact that
indeed those divisions were growing as
the media hype on the outside continued
to pump it there was you could go too
far as I've made very clear in this book
repeatedly many times over in taking
those divisions out you could go too far
in blowing those divisions out of
proportion ultimately at the site put it
this way this is a piece of American
ground we in the United States have many
arguments and serious arguments and
emotional arguments we disagree often
that is what this country is about that
is what that is about outside and we
also ultimately submit to the
Constitution there is that shared
understanding and we are not the Ivory
Coast we do not divide terminally over
these things but understand that there
is a higher order that has to has to
come into play at some point that was
very true at the site this was an
American ground a piece of it it was not
the Ivory Coast and despite the
divisions that existed there there was
an understanding of the severity of the
attack the level of personal tragedy for
thousands of people who had lost family
at the site and the need to to take that
into account to rise above the divisions
the pettiness which was certainly part
of the story as it is in the United
States to rise above stupidity which was
part of the story as it is in the United
States to unite around the act of
brilliance and innovation which is part
of the United States and to move forward
to an effective solution that's what
happened at the Trade Center site I
think at that point I should just end it
we're I could talk about this for a long
time but I think it's better to have a
short QA and then and and and cut it at
that time given given the the conditions
of the evening if you're going to ask a
question please wait for the boom mic to
arrive so that you will be picked up on
the tape thank you yes
I have a question about what was found
down at Ground Zero because you didn't
discuss that role in your talk and I
live about two blocks away from Ground
Zero about two weeks after the attack I
was told by many different police
officers that I happen to know
personally that they found the fire
truck with the gap genes there and I
read that once maybe two months after
that in a little blurb in an article on
like page 62 some ways that was the last
I heard of it it was the last anybody
ever spoke about it
now I didn't read your book and I just
bought it
okay I suspect that that was mentioned
in there that's why these guys are
outside yelling like can you tell us a
little bit about that and what evidence
you have about that let me tell you what
the nature of what I was writing about
okay again was what happened afterward
all right
yes in this book I reported that okay I
reported it because people who had
proved to be reliable to me
very steady who were active on the pile
had told me about it and then I had
sought and found further verification of
the details all right and I had and but
my interest in it was never what
actually had happened an explanation I
didn't care and in fact specifically
what I wrote was not about that
there were no I did not jump to
conclusions okay what I did do was
describe the effect that had on the pile
on the culture that that was my subject
in context therefore what I was writing
about in and masking all identities all
identities and with no conclusions no
implications was what was happening when
I was there not what had happened on
September 11th I was not my subject I
there for it to tell you the truth I
don't know and I never I'm not that's
not my subject okay
spit the specific story which has caused
so much turmoil needs to be taken in
contact
it needs be taken in context both of
what I wrote and more specifically it
needs to be taken in context of his site
that was not a normal part of America in
that sense but was a battlefield things
happen on battlefields it cannot be
measured by normal standards and I
understand that and I wrote in those
terms I think there may be a boom like a
problem there is there anything in your
book and I protect your explanation on
that shortly after the attacks the local
administration of politicians everything
did everything they could to keep
ordinary citizens away from the site
right they erected barricades right not
only the day erect barricades but they
also put a perma hedge or covering
language so ordinary citizens who felt
the need to go there or be there or see
completely the cops without pushing
people while you can't come here you
have to leave I live in the area and
that went on probably for about two
months two and a half months all during
a time they were marching celebrities
down there football players
autograph and football helmets but
ordinary citizens who had the same urges
the same desires to go there and just do
whatever it is they do were kept away
even from the visual sense of it was
there and I couldn't agree with you more
okay in other words I remember those
kind I was involved and I remember those
conversations I was there when the
orders were coming on not only to to
erect the perimeter to make it strong
but to make it opaque okay we know that
there was a sort of an implied insult
against anyone who wanted to come down
and look as if people were voyeurs okay
I found it so misguided and such a
fundamental I could not imagine being in
New York and not as an American wanting
to come down there I also asked around
the site quite a lot because I was so
astonished by that policy and I thought
be given the sense of possession that
was at that site people who were on the
inside did have a sense that this is my
disaster more than yours just as New
York had a feeling this is my disaster
more than yours for the rest of the US
there was that staggered sense of
possession
okay given that reality psychological
reality which I'm told is very much a
part of all disasters I expected that
people on the inside would say yeah
those people on the outside should stay
away they're just you know peeping toms
they didn't I never found a single
person on the inside a single person who
agreed with that policy those who knew
who understood what was going on the
significance of what was going on felt
it needed to be shared okay
and in fact finally the administration
the City Hall I mean woke up to that and
there was a viewing platform II just
took awhile I mean it's in a way look
there was a lot of confusion there were
other things going on the natural and
bureaucratic instinct was close it off
and you also need to say admit that the
that this opaque perimeter though it
caught though it was an implied insult
against legitimate curiosity was also a
very important factor in what happened
on the inside of that site because it
had to be opaque to some degree for
people to be creative and honest in
there and to take and to take the kind
of risks that almost everybody at the
site was taking both intellectual career
and physical risks that were going on
inside there you couldn't expose that to
the view of the outside world because
they would at the very least Christ
safety violation yes
what was your original intent when you
went down to the site you went on the
12th yeah I don't know if the actual day
no it's certainly not on the 12th it was
up I got there about a week after the
buildings came down was it your intent
to stay there and right now all right it
was I I was curious to see whether as an
Atlantic writer whether there would be
an engineering story here I certainly
had no political intent no agenda I'm
not a New Yorker I had no in no sort of
know New York political intent of any
kind as I do not now have either and I
went there is to look at the possibility
of it what proved to be what what
promised to be perhaps an interesting
engineering story and then it blossomed
beyond that very rapidly very rapidly
yes I recall reading I think in one of
the articles the severity of the
possibility of lower Manhattan being
completely flooded if you can elaborate
on that no I think that that that's
probably a slight overstatement there
was in the in the early in the first
moments of the attack when the buildings
fell there was concern about what is
known as or what was known as sequential
flooding if the path tubes had failed
which they did not there once that was
solved and there was no problem concrete
as you probably know concrete plugs were
built in New Jersey the problem was
solved and then there was however a very
real problem serious problem
with flooding at the site itself I'd
spent quite a lot of time in this book
on discussing the story of the slope the
South slurry wall that began to fail and
through enormous efforts and really
brilliant work and courageous work by
many people that was that problem was
solved so essentially flooding never
turned out to be the problem that could
have been but on several occasions that
could have been a very serious problem
well I would like to thank you all very
much for coming here and I appreciate
your you're doing a deniz in these in
these circumstances
William Lango Asia is author of American
ground on building the World Trade
Center it's published by North Point
press an imprint of Ferrer Straus and
Giroux
visit FSG books dot-com